hi everyone welcome to Yale my name is
Simone and I'm a senior majoring in
computer science and I'm Sam I'm a
junior double majoring in Classics and
political science and we will be your
tour guides today at Yale students
pursue both the Arts and the Sciences so
in one day you might do research at a
state-of-the-art lab with a Nobel Prize
winner and take a class at the Yale art
gallery is Embrace tradition and
Innovation so you might study with a
renowned Shake through a scholar and
perform slam poetry at a cultural center
you might build a robot and sing with an
acapella group debate public policy and
dance with Yale Josh and Bhangra excuse
me are we gonna see all this on the tour
we're certainly gonna try could we get a
little uh background music
[Music]
uh how about something with a Beat
follow us
deal offers more than 2 000 courses
every year and students can choose from
over 80 Majors there's no Core
Curriculum so we get to pick every one
of our courses ourselves and we don't
have to choose a major until the end of
our second year so classes come in all
sizes but three quarters of them enroll
fewer than 20 students so you might
choose to take a larger lecture course
like this
together with Yale students my
laboratory is developing techniques to
use brain Imaging to read out the mind
we can show participants faces as shown
here on the left decode their brain
activity patterns and guess or
reconstruct what they were seeing four
small discussion seminars like this
so what do we make of the fact that at
the height of World War II Winston
Churchill told Lawrence Olivier from the
service to make a film of Henry V well I
think it supports the notion that Henry
V should be considered the Great
Patriotic drama of the English
theatrical Canon
I've been trying to agree with you but
let's try the counter argument that
Henry was a serious warmonger whose
threat when doing independent research
you'll have access to some of the
world's most expansive libraries this
one Library holds over 4 million books
on 16 floors besides books it also
contains thousands of musical scores
maps and newspapers from around the
world
in the beinecke library you'll find one
of the world's largest collections of
rare books and manuscripts including
ancient Egyptian Papyrus one of
Beethoven's original scores and
manuscripts written by Langston Hughes
the marble walls filter sunlight to
preserve the books inside
Yale students learn by doing but there
were 800 science and engineering Labs a
24 7 Makerspace with state-of-the-art
equipment students can push past the
boundaries of their scientific curiosity
and innovate Solutions some of the
world's greatest challenges
Yale sponsors countless research
projects both on campus and abroad there
are over a hundred paid fellowships
reserved for first-year students in
science and engineering that means you
get access to hands-on experience in a
lab right away
[Music]
there are countless opportunities to
learn outside the classroom you might
learn about sustainable agriculture at
the Yale Farm
or record an original music composition
in a professional studio
you can learn a new foreign language
abroad on a Yale Fellowship you might
even take a class here at the Yale art
gallery
interesting use of color here but no
matter where your academic Journey takes
you you'll experience Yale's most
distinctive feature at the residential
colleges
[Music]
every incoming student is randomly
assigned to one of 14 residential
colleges the colleges have nothing to do
with your major they're just smaller
communities that reflect the diversity
of the student body each has its own
facilities events and traditions besides
just housing students the colleges are
also supportive communities that include
some of our most valued advisors
my name is Jorge and I'm a first year
counselor I was chosen by the college to
live among First Years and serve as a
senior advisor helping with everything
from homesickness to course selection to
finding the laundry room
I'm Jesse Hill
I support students through every
academic and personal challenge
[Music]
and I'm Dr Laurie Santos the head of
this college I shape the cultural social
and academic events in the college and I
ensure that each student feels welcome I
make sure to get to know every student
in the college one-on-one
check it
[Applause]
inside every College are awesome
facilities like game rooms with ping
pong and pool tables
common rooms where you can relax hang
out and unwind with your friends play
games
[Music]
[Applause]
space is like dance studios woodworking
shops music practice rooms and workout
rooms
and of course when you're craving that
Burger milkshake or other late night
snack the batteries
but perhaps the most important spot in
any Residential College is the dining
hall where you'll find great food and
great friends this college has a pizza
oven where I'm sorry to interrupt can we
hold for a sec
that's better okay right about now
you're probably wondering how could I
possibly afford to go to Yale
well the good news is Yale's need-based
financial aid meets a hundred percent of
your financial need
with awards that won't require you and
your family to take out loans if your
family's annual income is sixty five
thousand dollars a year or less then
there is no parent contribution at all
awards are calculated to include the
full cost of tuition books living on
campus and personal expenses Yale even
covers its students to study abroad
my point is
a Yale education is Affordable
for everyone
within the residential colleges students
live in Suites bedrooms are attached to
Common rooms where you can study and
hang out
Suites range in size from 3 to 12
students and you usually share a
bathroom with your roommates the bat
foreign
okay that's a wrap for rehearsal great
job today everyone can I talk to
wardrobe backstage you'll spend most of
your time outside your Suite though
participating in some of the hundreds of
student organizations at Yale like
theater and singing
make your voice heard in a political
group mock trial or a debate in today's
critical climate what we need is more I
couldn't agree more civil discourse
can join one of Yale's many dance groups
[Music]
and there are dozens of groups
affiliated with Yale's four cultural
centers
[Music]
build this house but I claim every beam
and bone as my own because here I find
people who will laugh with and tap me
but always out of love I find the
community that shows up when I ask them
to and especially when I don't with
every Gathering we build a home that
will last
[Music]
the best part is that your activities
don't have to have any connection to
your major you could join a music group
without taking a single music course you
might even start your own Jazz combo
[Music]
or you can play with the yellow Symphony
Orchestra
[Music]
you can stay active with more than 100
different athletic teams including
Varsity Club and intramural
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're just scratching the surface
Yale has over 500 student groups if you
have a passion you can pursue it
[Music]
if you want to try something new you can
try it
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you just go to the website
thank you
[Music]
foreign